welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange to the
multiverse of madness released new
official imagery via empire magazine two
covers for their may 2022 issue both of
which containing some mysterious visual
clues for what's in store for this film
now y'all asked me to break down
everything from the official movie
poster to the recent imax trailer
re-release and then some even have the
nerve to whine when a new cool detail i
find wasn't in one of the imac's margins
but just more visible now in 4k why do
you even care where a detail is found
just be happy that you have more reasons
to be hyped for this movie so anyway
asked and received here is my breakdown
of all the interesting stuff i spotted
hidden in this imagery let's actually
start with the main empire cover which
shows doctor strange among the crumbling
ruins of that setting that i have
thought to be the utopian parallel home
dimension of america chavez strange's
cloak of levitation floats off to the
right and then the interior lining of it
looks like it's covered with a
checkerboard pattern reminding us of the
importance of chess to dr strange i just
spotted a chess set among the
collections in that darker version of
the sanctum attic in the imax trailer
the chest said that i am dying to see
strange sit down with chess master
professor x for a game remember it was
strange who called back tony stark's
utterance of the word endgame in age of
ultron that up there that's that's the
end game strange calling it back and
infinity war to clue us into the title
for the next film we're in the end game
now in the game being a chess term
referring to the final stage of a game
in which critical sacrifices are often
made to corner your opponent's king this
movie multiverse of madness may show us
what the true end game of the mcu really
is more details actually can be spotted
on the alternate cover so let's start in
the one o'clock spot in the upper right
corner and then work our way clockwise
in this corner is the tentacle of
gargantos another one is directly beside
it smaller but the large one crushes
this car now we do need to be on the
lookout for a 1973 oldsmobile delta 88
in this movie director sam raimi
features this classic in every one of
his films from the evil dead series to
the spider-man trilogy and he confirmed
in a reddit ama that this car would
appear in a brief cameo in doctor
strange in the multiverse madness now i
doubt if this car is the delta however
because this looks blue but actually if
you go frame by frame through that part
of the multiverse madness trailer when
strange in america tumble past the
dinosaurs when they crash through a star
portal into an animated reality in that
cartoon dimension is a blue car that
looks a lot like the one on this cover
there's also a traffic cone visible
telling us this is on some kind of urban
street we pointed out how the animation
style in this reality does not have the
exact color shading that what if has
rather it's a simpler more old-school
animation style like the 90s x-men but
actually this could be an animated
version of that garganto street battle
now right below the gargantus tentacle
is the tyrannosaurus rex that also
appears in this moment in the trailer
battling the triceratops there is some
speculation that this could actually be
part of the savage land from the uncanny
x-men comics which is a tropical
prehistoric region hidden in antarctica
surrounded by volcanoes a series that
introduced us to the character sauron
others are wondering if this could be a
nod to devil dinosaur since disney
channel is launching a moon girl and
devil dinosaur series this summer i
don't know about that i really just
think this could be strange in america
crashing through a prehistoric setting
or since this is realities are crashing
through not time periods it could be a
reality where dinosaurs were never
rendered extinct by a global catastrophe
so moving down from the t-rex is that
hatch that we have seen in many trailers
the one that strange in america and
variant christine palmer open and look
out through there must be some
significance to this hatch in particular
actually in the imax trailer which again
shows all this footage in higher
definition you can now make out a sign
beside that door labeled unc
r our buddy mt pitched that this could
stand for uncle ralph boner but i don't
know if there'd be anything behind that
ralph's doors other than stacks and
stacks of his headshots now if you're
like me and spend a lot of your days
staring at screens like this you might
notice some sore eyes and problems
sleeping blue light
damages our eyes and leads to digital
eye strain the symptoms of which include
blurred vision headaches and dry watery
eyes for some folks this can even affect
your energy level
sorry well blue blocks was created to
fix this problem and block out the blue
light with these high quality lenses
thanks to blue blocks for sponsoring
this video blue blocks are
evidence-backed and made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia when
i'm spending time in fluorescent
lighting staring at screens these
glasses are a big help they have over 40
styles of frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers blue box also has other amazing
products such as low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and sleep
masks i'm a big fan of they ship
worldwide in rapid time and make returns
and exchanges easy so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars and use the
coupon code new rockstars to save twenty
percent that's
blueblox.com b-l-u-b-l-o-x
dot com slash new rockstars and use a
coupon code new rockstars to save 20
now in the bottom right corner is
america chavez her foot kicking downward
into a sling ring portal find this
ironic because slingering portals are
the one aspect of dr strange's magic
that thus far have shown up nowhere in
footage for this movie instead all the
portals we see seem to be practically
accessed through real doors or star
portals kicked open by america chavez in
the 2016 film mordo said this about
slingering portals mastery of the sling
ring is essential to the mystic arts
they allow us to travel throughout the
multiverse so the fact that no one seems
to be using these in multiverse of
madness suggests that this slingering
magic to travel the multiverse might
have been compromised in some way which
now requires strange to use other ways
to travel the multiverse then on this
cover under america's knee there's a
small purple silhouetted figure tumbling
out of or into that nearby portal
actually if you look closely you can see
this same where's waldo type figure in
the upper left corner of the cover
behind the e of empire now at the bottom
of the cover is another portal
containing an eye this looks like the
eye of gargantos and he is looking up at
wanda maximoff as she conducts her
seance surrounded by candles as we see
her do in the trailer if you look
closely you can even see her fingertips
have started to turn black as they do in
the footage matching the way agatha
harkness's hands turn black whenever she
uses this dark magic now in the bottom
left corner there's a chunk of brick
wall coming apart and above that in a
stone archway is defender strange and
then to the upper right of him supreme
version of mordo who i believe is one of
those seven members of the illuminati
and he wields a crossbow i wonder if
this could actually be the crossbow ned
found in the sanctum sanctorum
undercroft in spider-man no way home
then above him there's wang and then
another portal showing the minotaur
sorcerer rintra and that brings us to
the central elements of this cover
depicting doctor strange with 10 other
arms fanned out behind him mirroring the
final shot with the demon arms in the
trailer except these are all his own the
five on the left all have eldritch halos
behind them the five on the right do not
but they are all making this gesture and
by looking at it doctor strange now gets
to punch you in the shoulder i don't
know this is actually the gesture
strange makes to open and close the eye
of agamotto an eye that now looms large
behind strange here much like the giant
window of the supreme strange sanctum
sanctorum window behind that statue but
when you compare this eye to the eye
around strange's neck and the other
empire cover the wider set upper layer
of bands are twisted to go from the top
left to the bottom right of the ring
whereas the one worn by strange that top
layer is twisted 90 degrees to the right
that means that all of this madness and
the second cover is being unleashed by
strange twisting open the eye of
agamotto and you will notice one of
those threats snaking behind strange and
wanda in the center of the cover the
ribbony bands of that citrec monster if
it is a track and what's really creepy
is you don't see its face which if you
think about it it's really just formed
by the folds in gaps of the ribbons so
really anywhere there is one of these
ribbons could be part of this whole
thing's body it's just one long strand
all right that's everything i spotted in
this imagery you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you